wann
habt ihr zuletzt mein beispielsweise im
Callcenter von eurem Internetanbieter
angerufen und gesagt hey mein Internet
hat heute echt super gut funktioniert
oder wann habt ihr zuletzt nachdem ihr
Essen geliefert bekommen habt dem
Restaurant eine richtig positive
Rezension im Internet hinterlassen
das macht man irgendwie nie
man ist immer nur in diesem Bewertung
schreiben oder Call Center anrufen Modus
wenn irgendetwas nicht funktioniert
irgendwas vergessen wurde bei der
Bestellung wenn ein T-Shirt was ich
bestellt habe irgendwie in der falschen
Größe angekommen ist whatever und das
wollen wir heute ändern
[Musik]
ich werde heute auf Google Unternehmen
mit fünf Sternen bewerten um einfach
diesem hate ein bisschen
entgegenzuwirken und einfach ein
bisschen Positivität zu sprechen da ich
Kölner bin fangen wir natürlich mit dem
Humboldt-Gymnasium an das
Humboldt-Gymnasium Köln ist das größte
Gymnasium in der Kölner Innenstadt das
ist benannt nach dem deutschen
Naturforscher Alexander von Humboldt die
Schule ist ein sprachliches und
naturwissenschaftliches Gymnasium zu den
Besonderheiten zählt die starke
Ausrichtung auf Musikpädagogen und diese
Schule ist wirklich super
also ich war da noch nie und bin auch
nicht zur Schule gegangen aber wir geben
jetzt einfach mal eine super gute
Bewertung ein paar Sekunden später
[Musik]
wurde damals gezwungen eine gute Wertung
zu geben ich empfehle die Schule nicht
weiter es gibt bessere Schulen für ihre
Kinder und wo sie Abitur machen können
wenn Sie mehr über die Schule erfahren
wollen einfach mir schreiben okay leute
das ist doch nicht die beste Schule sind
die Bewertungen
du Hund schreibst ein Ort um go was zu
finden oder hier auch
WC und Kantine sehr sauber Bro was soll
ich noch um die Schule gehen heute da
also ich fange jetzt mal meine Rezension
an erstmal geben wir dem ganzen
natürlich fünf Sterne und fang mal
direkt von Beginn an mit dem äußeren der
Schule das
äußere Erscheinungsbild
Sprachen lernen Babbel das äußere
Erscheinungsbild des Humboldt-Gymnasiums
begeistert mit seiner
farbintensiven
Architektur die im Kölner Raum seines
gleichen sucht was mir besonders gefällt
ist dass die Kinder dort nicht in
Klammern wie bei anderen
Schulen
dauernd um irgendwelche Baustellen
herumlaufen müssen
des Weiteren ist dieser Ort kein Tatort
für
Sprayer oder etwaige andere
Graffiti
Verbrechen da alles immer schön sauber
gesäubert wird
geschaffen
[Musik]
ganz klar fünf Sterne du kannst local
guide werden nein danke machen wir dann
weiter kebapland Köln
besser Imbiss in ganz Köln sieht man
halt einfach auch anhand der Bewertung
hier die haben durchschnittlich 4,7
Sterne bei 5800 Rezensionen
und habe mich gefühlt
so eine Frage hast du Note aufgezaubert
hat dass ich danach Menschen heißt
angezauberten wurde und mein Leben
lang top machen wir mal weiter mit der
Telekom und zwar einem Telekom Shop
Mobiltelefon Geschäft in Köln kriegen
natürlich selbstverständlich auch fünf
Sterne als Bewertung schreiben wir
suchen
[Musik]
ausgesprochen
wird geschweige denn nicht
zusammengeschrieben nein meine
freundliche und zudem auch noch wieder
aus attraktive Mitarbeiterin hat mir
dann die Historie das Telefonieren günst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass es diesen Shop gibt Herz Herz
wir tun heute richtig was Gutes
oh mein Gott ich Idiot ihr könnt euch
alle meine Bewertung nachher noch
durchlesen hier ne ich bin übrigens auf
die Idee gekommen weil ich letztens mit
einer Freundin was essen war und sie in
einem Call Center arbeitet im
Kundencenter und tagtäglich Anrufe
entgegen nimmt von primär Leuten die
wirklich unzufrieden sind und ich denke
sie kann ja nichts dafür sie spielt
quasi den Boxsack und das ist total
unfair deswegen schreiben wir heute mal
ein paar positive Bewertungen und ich
habe auch vor ein paar Tagen direkt
schon angefangen bei meinem Barber das
Vertrauens Francesco Abbey Bottini il
Barbieri da habe ich nämlich das hier
drunter geschrieben
irgendwie irgendwas krasses auf
Italienisch
kein Plan Kölner Dom der Kölner Dom hat
eine Durchschnittsbewertung von 4,8 und
fast 60.000 Rezensionen 5 Sterne kriegt
er natürlich schon mal
er ist halt eine Kirche ne
Tierchen
Monaten Bruder
[Musik]
ist tatsächlich ein super Schuh und die
Engel im Kölner Dom zu erkennen und die
500 Stufen so weiter das Jesus damals in
Köln war und dieses Gotteshaus
geschaffen und erbaut hat ich hoffe ich
komme nicht in die Hölle für solche
jokes aber dahinter Gedanke sehr gut ich
will ja Orte mit fünf Sternen bewerten
so dass wir alle irgendwie davon
profitieren keine Ahnung wie wir davon
profitieren kann ich youtube bewerten so
geht Youtube ein
online-marketing-unternehmen in Köln der
Kurs mit Jana hat mir wirklich sehr
geholfen die Tipps waren verständlich
ich folge Jan so geht Youtube schon seit
Jahren sowie Youtube sowies
o
ja mann
Alter
welche Unternehmen soll ich im nächsten
Video bewerten schreibst du immer unten
in die Kommentare lassen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video da wird es euch gefallen
hat abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt
auf die Glocke um weitere Videos nicht
zu verpassen ich gehe jetzt in Kölner
Dom und danach zu Kebab